>>> A U.S. COURT HAS JUST
REVEALED A SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
BETWEEN CONVICTED SEX TRAFFICKER
JEFFREY EPSTEIN AND VIRGINIA
GIUFFRE AND IT COULD AFFECT HER
LAWSUIT AGAINST PRINCE ANDREW.
SHE SAYS SHE WAS SEX TRAFFICKED
BY EPSTEIN AND FORCED TO HAVE
SEX WITH PRINCE ANDREW AND SHE
SAID THE PRINCE KNEW SHE WAS
UNDER AGE.
HE HAS STRONGLY DENIED THE
ALLEGATIONS.
THE 2009 SETTLEMENT BETWEEN
EPSTEIN AND GIUFFRE THAT WAS
MADE PUBLIC TODAY DOES NOT
MENTION PRINCE ANDREW DIRECTLY,
BUT IT SAYS THAT GIUFFRE WILL
RELEASE LIABILITY FOR, QUOTE,
ANY OTHER PERSON WHO COULD HAVE
BEEN A DEFENDANT AGAINST HER
CLAIMS.
ORAL ARGUMENTS IN THE CASE
AGAINST PRINCE ANDREW BEGIN
TOMORROW, AND THE PRINCE'S LEGAL
TEAM IS EXPECTED TO ARGUE FOR
DISMISSAL BASED ON THIS 2009
SETTLEMENT.
CNN'S LEGAL ANALYST PAUL COWEN
JOINS ME FROM NEW YORK WITH
MORE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE CHANCES OF
PRINCE ANDREW'S LEGAL TEAM ARE
IN COURT TOMORROW?
THEY'RE BASICALLY SAYING GIUFFRE
SIGNED A DEAL IN 2009 PROMISING
NOT TO PURSUE ANYONE CONNECTED
WITH EPSTEIN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A VERY
STRONG ARGUMENT, A COMPELLING
ARGUMENT THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
ASSERT ON BEHALF OF PRINCE
ANDREW.
AN AGREEMENT LIKE THIS, A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT LIKE THIS
IS NOT AT ALL UNUSUAL.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, IN MOST
CIVIL CASES WHEN THEY ARE
SETTLED THE DEFENDANT, THE
PERSON WHO IS BEING SUED, IS
ALWAYS AFRAID THERE WILL BE
OTHER SUITS THAT WILL BE COMING
OUT OF THE SAME INCIDENT.
SO IF THEY CAN, THEY NEGOTIATE
AN AGREEMENT LIKE THIS THAT,
HEY, THIS IS THE END OF THE CASE
IF WE'RE GOING TO PAY YOU THIS
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THEY PAID HER $500,000
APPARENTLY BACK IN 2009, I
BELIEVE IT WAS, WHEN THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT WAS MADE.
>> OKAY.
SO THIS IS THE EXACT LANGUAGE.
I'M GOING TO READ IT TO OUR
VIEWERS.
GIUFFRE SIGNED THE DEAL IN WHICH
SHE AGREED TO RELEASE, ACQUIT,
SATISFY AND FOREVER DISCHARGE
THE SAID SECOND PARTIES AND ANY
OTHER PERSON OR ENTITY WHO COULD
HAVE BEEN INCLUDED AS A
POTENTIAL DEFENDANT FROM ALL AND
ALL MANNER OF ACTION AND ACTIONS
OF VIRGINIA ROBERTS, THAT WAS
HER NAME AT THE TIME, INCLUDING
STATE OR FEDERAL CAUSE AND
CAUSES OF ACTION.
DOES THAT INCLUDE CIVIL SUITS?
>> OH, YES, THAT WOULD MOST
DEFINITELY.
THAT IS REALLY AIMED AT CIVIL
SUITS BECAUSE YOU CANNOT
CONTRACT AWAY CRIMINAL CHARGES.
THAT WOULD BE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE IF YOU DID THAT.
>> SURE.
>> SO THIS IS INTENDED TO APPLY
TO CIVIL CASES.
BUT HERE IS THE ARGUMENT THAT
HER ATTORNEYS ARE GOING TO MAKE.
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY THAT THE
CASE AGAINST PRINCE ANDREW IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE CASE AGAINST
EPSTEIN, AND, ACCORDINGLY, IT
COULD NOT HAVE APPROPRIATELY
BEEN BROUGHT AS PART OF THIS
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT AND, HENCE,
IT IS NOT COVERED.
THAT'S WHAT THE LAWYERS WILL BE
ARGUING ABOUT FROM A TECHNICAL
STANDPOINT.
NOW, OF COURSE, HER ATTORNEYS
WILL BE -- RATHER PRINCE
ANDREW'S ATTORNEYS WILL BE
SAYING, HEY, THAT'S ABSURD.
HE COULD HAVE BEEN NAMED AS A
CO-DEFENDANT IN THE CASE JUST AS
MAXWELL WAS NAMED AS A
CO-DEFENDANT IN THE CASE.
>> SURE.
WHAT IF GHISLAINE MAXWELL, WHO
WAS FOUND GUILTY ON FIVE OF SIX
CHARGES AGAINST HER, DECIDES,
FOR INSTANCE, TO TALK ABOUT
ANYTHING INVOLVING PRINCE ANDREW
AND VIRGINIA GIUFFRE, COULD THAT
AFFECT GIUFFRE'S CIVIL SUIT
AGAINST PRINCE ANDREW DESPITE
THE 2009 SETTLEMENT THAT SHE
SIGNED?
>> I DON'T THINK IT WOULD AFFECT
GIUFFRE'S CIVIL SUIT.
IT WOULD, OF COURSE, MEAN THAT
HE COULD BE CHARGED POSSIBLY
WITH CRIMINAL CHARGES, DEPENDING
UPON, OF COURSE, WHAT MAXWELL
HAS TO SAY.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE STATUE OF
LIMITATION ISSUES IN THIS CASE
AND THERE ARE ALSO ISSUES WITH
RESPECT TO SOME OF THE SEXUAL
CONDUCT THAT'S ALLEGED, THAT THE
PRINCE IS ALLEGE TO HAVE ENGAGED
IN WAS IN LONDON AND THE LAWS
ARE DIFFERENT IN ENGLAND THAN
THEY ARE IN THE UNITED STATES
WITH RESPECT TO STATUTES OF
LIMITATIONS AND SO FORTH.
>> SURE.
NOW, WE'VE BEEN FOLLOWING
OBVIOUSLY THIS CASE AND
GIUFFRE'S TEAM HAS ASKED PRINCE
ANDREW'S TEAM TO PROVIDE PROOF
THAT HE WAS SUFFERING FROM SOME
SORT OF MEDICAL CONDITION THAT
PREVENTED HIM FROM SWEATING.
YOU WILL REMEMBER IN A BBC
INTERVIEW HE SAID GIUFFRE'S
CLAIMS ARE IM PLAUSIBLE AND IM
PROBABLE BECAUSE SHE CLAIMED HE
WAS SWEATING PROFUSELY IN A
NIGHTCLUB AND HE SAID, I
COULDN'T SWEAT.
IF HE CANNOT PRODUCE EVIDENCE
AND PROOF THAT HE WAS, IN FACT,
SUFFERING FROM THIS RARE AND
UNUSUAL MEDICAL CONDITION, CAN
ANY OF THAT HAVE AN IMPACT ON
ANY CIVIL SUIT THAT GIUFFRE'S
TEAM BRINGS AGAINST PRINCE
ANDREW?
>> WELL, IF THE JUDGE IN THIS
CASE LOOKS AT THIS GENERAL
RELEASE AND SAYS, YOU KNOW
SOMETHING?
IT IS NOT GOING TO BAR PRINCE
ANDREW FROM BEING SUED BY
GIUFFRE, IF THAT'S THE CASE THEN
THIS SWEATING ISSUE ACTUALLY IS
GOING TO BECOME A HUGE ISSUE IN
THE CASE.
IT WILL BE VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE SHE SAYS HE WAS SWEATING
PROFUSELY WHEN THE SEXUAL
ENCOUNTER OCCURRED AND, OF
COURSE, HE SAYS THAT MEDICALLY
HE CAN'T SWEAT.
SO THAT'S WHY GIUFFRE'S
ATTORNEYS HAVE -- THEY WANT HIS
MEDICAL RECORDS.
THEY WANT TO SEE PROOF OF THIS
BIZARRE CONDITION THAT WOULD
PREVENT HIM FROM SWEATING.
>> LASTLY, IF THE JUDGE AGREES
WITH PRINCE ANDREW'S TEAM AND
RULES THAT THIS 2009 SETTLEMENT,
IN FACT, SHIELDS PRINCE ANDREW
FROM ANY CIVIL SUIT BROUGHT BY
GEORGIA GIUFF
VIRGINIA GIUFFRE, IS THAT THE
END OF IT FOR HIM?
IS HE IN THE CLEAR?
>> IT IS THE END OF IT FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF A CIVIL SUIT FOR
MONEY DAMAGES.
HOWEVER, CRIMINAL LIABILITY
MIGHT STILL LIE BECAUSE
DEPENDING UPON WHERE SHE SAYS
THE SEXUAL MISCONDUCT, SEXUAL
ABUSE OCCURRED, THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS MIGHT STILL BE
ALIVE.
IT REALLY DEPENDS UPON THE
DETAILS OF THAT AND WHAT THE LAW
WAS IN THE JURISDICTION AT THAT
TIME.
SO, YES, HE MAY STILL HAVE
CRIMINAL LIABILITY.
HE'S NOT OUT OF THE WOODS YET
EVEN IF THE JUDGE RULES IN FAVOR
ON THIS ISSUE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
PAUL CALLAN, AS ALWAYS, THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU, HALA.
>> HOPE YOU HAVE A HAPPY NEW
YEAR.
>> OKAY.
YOU TOO.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> LET'S GET TO CNN ROYAL
CORRESPONDENT MAX FOSTER.
HE IS IN HAMPSHIRE FOR MORE.
NOW MORE PRESSURE PLACED ON
PRINCE ANDREW AND IT IS A REALLY
CRITICAL DAY TOMORROW FOR THE
BRITISH ROYAL.
>> Reporter: IT IS, BECAUSE AS
WE'VE BEEN HEARING THAT IS THE
DAY THE JUDGE RULES ON WHETHER
OR NOT THE CASE SHOULD BE THROWN
OUT OR NOT.
THERE ARE ALL SORTS OF
TECHNICALITIES YOU WERE
DISCUSSING THERE THAT NEED TO BE
GONE OVER.
HE IS NOT NAMED SPECIFICALLY IN
THIS AGREEMENT BUT ROYALTY IS
NAMED.
ALL OF THIS DEBATE IS REALLY
ACADEMIC AT THIS POINT.
IT IS UP TO THE JUDGE WHAT THE
COURT MAKES OF THIS DOCUMENT,
WHETHER IT SHOULD STAND IN THIS
CASE.
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT FOR PRINCE
ANDREW.
YOU HAVE THE LEGAL CASE HERE BUT
YOU HAVE THE COURT OF PUBLIC
OPINION, AND THE LONGER THIS
GOES ON, THE MORE SORDID
DETAILS, THE MORE WE ANALYZE
WHETHER OR NOT HE SWEATS AND
WHETHER OR NOT THERE ARE
DOCUMENTS TO BACK UP THAT
SWEATING, IT IS JUST VERY SORDID
INFORMATION, WHICH ALL REFLECTS
ON THE ROYAL BRAND WHICH AT THIS
TIME WE'RE NOT HEARING ANYTHING
FROM THE PALACE OR THE REST OF
THE FAMILY.
THEY'RE TRYING TO PROJECT IT ALL
ON TO PRINCE ANDREW'S LEGAL
TEAM, BUT THEY'RE INEXTRICABLY
LINKED, OF COURSE.
WE ARE ALSO HEARING FROM VOICES
WITHIN THE MILITARY BUBBLING UP,
IN THE BRITISH NEWSPAPERS SAYING
HE SHOULD BE LOSING HIS
REMAINING MILITARY TITLES
BECAUSE IT IS SO EMBARRASSING
FOR EVERYONE INVOLVED.
>> WHAT DOES HE DO NOW ON A
DAILY BASIS?
HE IS NOT DOING ANYMORE CHARITY
WORK.
HE IS NOT A WORKING ROYAL.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THESE MILITARY
VOICES CALLING FOR SOME OF
HIS -- YOU KNOW, HIS STATUS, HIS
POSITION WITHIN THE MILITARY TO
BE REMOVED.
WHAT IS HE DOING?
>> WELL, IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO
KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING BEHIND
THE SCENES.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THE QUEEN, FOR
EXAMPLE, WOULD STRIP HIM OF
THOSE REMAINING TITLES, WHICH DO
GIVE HIM A PUBLIC ROLE.
I THINK WHAT WOULD TYPICALLY
HAPPEN BEHIND THE SCENES IS THAT
SHE MIGHT ASK HIM TO RESIGN FROM
THOSE ROLES.
THERE MIGHT BE THOSE DEBATES
GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES.
I THINK WHAT HE IS TRYING TO DO
IS TRYING TO STAY OUT OF PUBLIC
VIEW, FRANKLY, BECAUSE EVEN A
PHOTO OF HIM DRIVING THROUGH
WINDSOR IN HIS CAR MAKES FRONT
PAGE NEWS AT THE MOMENT.
THE REST OF HIS FAMILY IS
CURRENTLY SKIING.
HE WOULD NORMALLY JOIN THEM.
HE'S NOT THERE BECAUSE HE KNOWS
THERE WILL BE PHOTOS.
IT IS AFFECTING EVERY PART OF
HIS LIFE.
HE IS TRYING TO STAY OUT OF
PUBLIC VIEW.
I THINK, FRANKLY, AT THE MOMENT
IF YOU TOOK A POLL IN THE
BRITISH PUBLIC, THEY WOULD
PROBABLY WANT HIM TO STAY OUT OF
PUBLIC VIEW PERMANENTLY.
PERHAPS THIS IS A DEBATE FOR
WHAT HAPPENS OUT OF THIS CASE,
YOU KNOW.
LET'S SEE WHAT THE RESULT IS AND
WHETHER OR NOT HE CAN REBUILD
THAT IMAGE, BUT THE LONGER IT
GOES ON I THINK THE HARDER IT
IS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
AGAIN, REMINDING OUR VIEWERS
PRINCE ANDREW HAS ALWAYS DENIED
ANY WRON